un sourire libertines chamois que tu
parles et roy diane roy sous les jupons
de l'histoire avec christine bravo
mercredi 16 octobre à 20h45 sur chérie
et alors
christine et si vous vous partez à la
découverte de lieux historiques et vous
dévoile été des moments d'histoire alors
sur chérie 25 ans quand on sait que
c'est la même là même la même maison qui
nrj 12 c'est bien ça nous fait du bien
de voir ça sur chérie 25 et les voilà
l'île des vérités sur sur nrj 12
oui voilà mais je suis pas mal compte
tenu à tant d adapter un mois qu'est ce
qui se passe est grave et quand on dit
ou un essai que la belle va bien hello
there il ya des risques voire pas du
tout là puisqu'elle a coûté la santé
mais je ne la protège mais c'est pas
grave
discrètement après ben ali
allez vous êtes dégoûtés jusqu'à l'idée
de faire un retour en telle aux attentes
qu'est ce qui se passe j'ai regardé
démission ouais et j'ai vu que tu
parlais beaucoup de cul c'est normal tu
parles de catherine de médicis et tout à
coup je tombe sur un extrait où tu
parles de
de danse le brol et donc non mais el
hammam et c'est pas moi c'est là tu
dragues un des chroniqueurs qui est
médecin